[Musique]
regin chantier pour les acteurs de l'eau
dans le cadre de la journée mondiale de
l'eau il fallait sensibiliser les
populations sur cette action essentielle
au développement du territoire
le département a lancé une analyse que
les ressources en eau et les besoins en
eau du bassin sud
le département a décidé de réaliser
réservoir supplémentaire d'une capacité
de vingt mille mètres cubes à côté du
réservoir existants ainsi coûté couper
que dix villes sur l'île les chiffres de
la politique globale de l'eau
impressionne seize mille hectares
irrigués 35% de la production d'eau
potable 75 millions de mètres cubes
distribué par an chaque année la
collectivité investit 20 millions
d'euros dans la gestion de l'eau et de
l'aménagement hydraulique est l'un des
bénéficiaires de ce progrès c'est le
monde agricole
mon la réunion connaît l'une des pires
sécheresses de son histoire
j'ai encore beaucoup de choses à
accomplir un je viens de citer par
exemple les hauts de l'ouest en exemple
mais dans le sud avec la dynamique auto
la safi a mais aussi l'engagement du
département qui est à souligner envers
son agriculture envers cette agriculture
réunionnaise donc les féliciter pour ce
travail donc ce sont vingt mille mètres
cubes de plus qui vont être stockés à
des à destination de la population mais
aussi des agriculteurs donc ce sont des
capacités supplémentaires cette année
avec une sécheresse historique
il n'y a pas eu de coupure d'eau dans
les chambres
sur le papier comme sur le terrain la
construction de ce réservoir à ciel
ouvert en béton armé de vingt mille
mètres cubes est phénoménal il
complétera à celui de 10 mille mètres
cubes un réseau interconnecté dans une
dynamique de hub
c'est vraiment un bain parce qu'on a à
la fois des infractions départementale
donc l'eau dérivés depuis le barrage du
bras de la plaine
on a effectivement les infrastructures
de la civis donc avec une station de
potabilisation en cours de construction
qui va desservir l'ensemble de la ville
de saint pierre
on a également un refoulement d'eau vers
la casud donc cette eau qui est ici
stocker et collecté est destiné au final
à l'ensemble des intercommunalités pour
les besoins en eau potable
intercommunalités du sud mais également
pour l'ensemble du monde agricole il
faut savoir qu'une partie de l'eau qui
est stocké ici par effectivement en
direction de la zone basse au niveau de
la ravine des cabris bois d'olives
pourrait turbiner pour produire de
l'énergie renouvelable
avant d'être re délivré au niveau de la
zone agricole basse au niveau de
pierrefonds pour faire en sorte qu
agricole eau potable et production
d'énergie renouvelable soit au final une
pratique un peu global c'est ce qu'on
appelle aussi la gestion globale de
l'eau département une vision intégrée de
l'eau car nous ne faisons qu emprunté
cette ressource ce patrimoine naturel
il ya forcément une vision patrimoniale
de la ressource en eau d'une façon
générale l'eau comme tout le monde le
sait maintenant c'est un cycle on est
bien sur cette notion de d'emprunt que
les générations actuelles font aux
générations futures
ces ouvrages livrés en début d'année
prochaine auront coûté neuf millions
d'euros
une manière de sécuriser la ressource et
ainsi de voir l'avenir de ces terres du
sud avec optimisme